now we take a repulsive aspect
so already only from the moment
I begin to open a being there and that
I start to in love people are
already intrigued and well to lay screws
banks
I explain to them so I cook that I
am going to make a giant dish on our body
[Music]
joe servers before at the agent covers
any form openly foods that
are not necessarily good for the health
will be able to do something that will
become an appetizing or who will not be
necessarily for our body
[Music]
[Applause]
that interests me at once
transforms and the gaze of passers-by
put there they ignored five minutes
earlier in the face finally lifting the
returning they will be opposed